[Music]
you don't know everything about me
i've lived a lot of lives
[Music]
before i was an avenger
before i got this family
i mean mistakes choosing between what
the world wants you to be
and who you are
[Music]
we have to go back to where it all
started
where did you think i was all this time
we have unfinished business
my girls are the toughest girls in the
world i'm sorry
we had our orders and we played the rule
it wasn't real
it was real to me
to me you were everything
[Music]
[Music]
oh
one thing's for sure
[Music]
i'm done running for my past
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i say either you say either
i say neither can i say neither
either neither neither let's
call the whole thing off
catch up excuse me
yummy
good evening eddie hey mrs chen good
evening venom
mrs
[Music]
you and i are the same
every decision we ever make
[Music]
who do we leave behind and how
do we leave them waiting
in the darkness for the rescuer who
never comes
welcome back eddie brock it's been a
long time
miss you so much
soon come chaos
chaos
the chocolate delivery hasn't arrived
yet no we had a deal
what's gonna happen you're gonna stop
protecting me i am happy to eat mrs chen
no no you cannot eat mrs chen what
nothing
all right so gave us a fake name again
again
not shocked i just don't understand why
he keeps doing this you don't understand
i feel like it's pretty obvious to spoil
things
i don't spoil things you're thinking
maybe one thing that i've actually
spoiled
the last movie title
you gotta be kidding me you're gonna
risk the entire mission for a mental
defective dress as a court justice it's
coming from a guy that wears a toilet
seat on his head we don't leave one of
our own behind hopefully harley's still
alive
no funny business these are dangerous
people
team two is clear to go fire uh three
two what are you guys doing what
you were here to save you you were gonna
save me it was a really good plan too
i can go back inside and you can still
do it that's patronizing i'm so sorry
harley quinn bloodsport
[Music]
you know the deal successfully complete
the mission you get 10 years off your
sentence
[Music]
you fail to follow my orders in any way
and i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your skull
this is the famous suicide squad
any questions
and yes that is your hand very good
we're all gonna die i hope so
oh for [ __ ] sake here's the deal
we fail admission you die we find out
any information you give us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you don't what no if you cough without
covering your mouth early although
that isn't an open invitation for you to
cough without covering your mouth
what's the plan uh how much listen up
you're the leader you're supposed to be
decisive and i've decided that you
should eat a big bag of dicks
if this whole beach was completely
covered in dicks and somebody said i'd
eat every dick until the beach was clean
for liberty i would say no problem
why would someone put penises all over
the beans well that's why mad men do
what they do
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing
don't you worry i'm gonna get you out of
your life i'm going to get you
out of here alive
[Applause]
oh my god we've got a freaking kaiju up
in this [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
i love the rain like angels are
splooting all over us
so
from your secret friend underneath
having
let's play a game just me and you
any of this mean anything to you
[Music]
you're becoming quite a celebrity
why is he writing to you
if you are justice
please do not lie
what is the price for your blind
eye
[Music]
the hell are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance
[Music]
you're part of this too
oh my part of it
you'll see
hey i gave you 10 years to live your
life
[Music]
now you see me rise and where did that
get you
you walked in my shadow
i trained you
so the most dangerous people in the
world
couldn't kill you
son it's time for you to take your place
by my side
[Music]
you can't run
who you really are
who are you
[Music]
[Applause]
okay hold on everybody
we make a good team
michael i've known you since you were a
child
you're a gift you always have
if there's an answer to the disease
you'll find it
i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this could be my last chance
[Music]
you're up to something what is it that's
not exactly legal
this would be a cure
at what cost
what's happening i went from dying
i feel like more alive than ever
increased strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
it's an overpowering urge to consume
blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael got tired of doing the whole
good guy thing huh
what's up doc
i love being with people it's the most
incredible thing
in the world what are you doing
oh this is nice that world may change
and evolve
but the one thing that will never change
we're all part of
one big family
that man next to you he's your brother
that woman over there she's your sister
hire further faster baby that's right
we're all part of one universe
that moves ever upward and onward to
greater glory
[Music]
on your left
[Applause]
[Applause]
avengers
[Applause]
[Applause]
i've lived a lot of lives
but i'm done running for my past
we have unfinished business who's we
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you love something you fight for it
[Music]
we're the ones who change everything
[Music]
[Music]
five thousand years ago kondok was a
melting pot of cultures
wealth
yet most of us had nothing except for
the chains
around our necks conduct needed a hero
instead they got me i did what needed to
be done
and they imprisoned me for it
[Music]
now five thousand years later
i'm free and i give you my word
no one will ever stop me again
[Music]
you